[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mainfeld
meine lieben freunde unter der letzten
folge minecraft mit luca wo ich diese
strandhaus will hier fertig gebaut habe
erst mal ich weiß ich habe das letzte
video beendet dadurch dass ich das
klopapier gebaut habe ich jetzt auch
nicht gedacht dass das der letzte der
letzte des blockes den ich setze in
dieser standort will allerdings wurde
mir eine menge sachen in die kommentare
geschrieben da oben habe ich euch auch
gebeten dass mir vorschläge werde die
kommentare schreiben könnt was sich
eventuell an der einen oder anderen
stelle noch ein bisschen anders bauen
könnte da gehe ich nachher darauf einen
einen vorschlag fand ich extrem geil und
sehr kreativ dass sie wahrscheinlich
auch schon im titel hat etwas mit
netflix zu tun jetzt nicht mit zahlt
schön wärs allerdings müssen wir uns
zuvor um zwei andere sachen kümmern und
zwar wurde mir das ebenfalls und in die
kommentare geschrieben denn da wurde mir
geschrieben lukas du brauchst eine
steintreppe einen rahmen und benötigt
auch noch eine fackel wenn du was
richtig bauen willst nicht so eine
mittelalterliche fackel
situation die auch zeitlich situation in
diesem projekt macht gar keinen sinn
allerdings wollte ich das mal testen
deswegen einen rahmen eine steintreppe
und eine fackel ich weiß nicht so ganz
genau wo wir das machen können
vielleicht hier das passt nicht so
richtig mit ich da oben haben wir
laternen wo könnte man dann eventuell
noch eine fackel gebrauchen vielleicht
hier in dem häuschen das auch nicht wir
könnten uns vielleicht hier drüber
setzen haben allerdings auch schon
laterne wir haben eigentlich alles schon
ausgebrochen
naja ich mal machen also ich setze jetzt
hier eine fackel dran dann einen rahmen
und in den rahmen kommt die scheint
ich glaube das könnte mit einer steinen
stufe vielleicht besser aussehen
probieren was jetzt einfach mal mit der
stein stufe und setzten die hier rein
das sieht auf jeden fall sehr sehr wild
aus also das könnte wirklich so eine
mittelalter fackel darstellen mit so
einer halterung hier mit diesem stein
dinge also danke dir da auf jeden fall
für den tipp in staffel zwei werde ich
das auf jeden fall häufiger so bauen
sieht sehr sehr wild aus wer hat nur
noch geld wenn man jetzt den rahmen ihm
wegnehmen könnte aber nicht auf jeden
fall sehr cool aus was wir allerdings
auch noch geschrieben wurde war
flughafen kartstrecke da musste was mit
red storm machen damit du da am ende und
am anfang von den strecken vernünftig
ein und aussteigen kannst ich idiot war
ist jetzt natürlich wieder nicht ganz
genau wie das funktionieren soll
allerdings wollte irgendwas mit der
retter und china gesagt ich glaube mal
sie meint eine antrieb stehen ich habe
sicher hat auch noch eine aktivierung
schüler mitgenommen allerdings kann ich
dir jetzt dahin setzen dann nehme ich
meine steine machen wir jetzt mal zwei
stein knöpfe und könnte den jetzt
einfach hier dran setzen und dann hier
in das mein kathrein und
perfekte ja ich komme ich an den knopf
dran ich kann es mir hier vorne
theoretisch probieren wenn ich hier die
redstone fakten einfach mal weg nehmen
würde und jeden knopf aufsetzen würde
und dann mich hier rein setzt und dann
den knopf drücke
die kirche sieht echt geil aus
vielleicht verwechsle ich allerdings
gerade natürlich auch die schienen von
daher setze ich jetzt mal eine
aktivierung schienen vielleicht macht
das den unterschied wenn ich jetzt den
knopf drückt
danke für deinen tipp aber ich bin ich
zu dumm und daher hier wieder die rap
song fackeln hin die schiene da vorne
ist auf jeden fall gebaut und dann
können wir hier von auch das ding
abbauen und da wieder eine ganz normale
schiene hinsetzen die mine cards bzw
loren was ich jetzt auch mal stehen die
sache ist allerdings dass wir uns gleich
sogar bewegen müssen nicht in den main
card könnte man auch aber ich würde er
mit dem boot fahren wir in die richtung
nach hinten müssen denn jetzt kommen wir
nach diesen zwei tipps ich mir die
kommentare geschrieben wurden auch
endlich mal zu dem was im titel steht
und was ich sehr kritisch sehe aber ich
weiß auch nicht so ganz gut
funktionieren wird bevor wir allerdings
zu diesem plan kommen muss ich mir erst
mal eine anti sieht stufe nehmen und ich
benötige noch zwei schwarzen trocken
beton davon habe ich jetzt nur einen das
heißt ich nehme mal ganz kurz jemand
schwarzen farbstoff raus und stibitzt
mich auch hier fordern ich will nicht
mit dem zweiten stück ist mir auch hier
sand und kies raus denn ich möchte den
fernseher bei uns in der strandhaus
villa um einen block erweitern nach
links das macht glaube ich mehr sinn
weil es dann mittig ist mit unserem
bettchen und da bin ich sehr penibel wie
er mich natürlich kennt und möchte
natürlich dass gerade in so einem
projekt hier bei minecraft mit luca was
ja sehr von der ganzen jacqueline hat
lebt also diese strandhaus wieder davon
rege ich jetzt gerade da möchte ich
natürlich auch das als perfektes
deswegen libet mitte ist halt genau hier
und wenn wir uns dann umdrehen ist der
fernseher ist er rechts verschoben
deswegen erweitern wir den um einen und
das kommt uns auf zu gute denn hier
kommen ein netflix logo rein es ist
nicht gesponsert von netflix das ist
schon geil
war ja ich schon sehr alles
hört sich dumm an aber ich find das
geilste dieser stoffe das wirklich die
toilette mit dem club ich möchte auf
jeden fall eine netflix logo bana in
meinen schwarzen trocken beton fernseher
in der modernen strandhaus villa
platzieren ich glaube das sei ganz geil
aus und ich will auch endlich mal was
mit dem webstuhl machen das ist nämlich
das ding in minecraft womit man bei na
ja so ein bisschen modifizieren kann man
eine eigene kleine
designs reinmachen sage ich mal und das
ist auf jeden fall sehr geil ich habe
ein video dazu im internet gefunden wie
man angeblich netflix büro herstellen
kann dafür benötigen wir allerdings
bereits gesagt den webstuhl und für
einen webstuhl benötigen die zwei seide
und die sache ist der aufmerksame
minecraft luca zuschauer weiß dass
wir haben leider keine seite mehr die
befand sich immer hier oben drin oder
halt hier unten drin wir haben die
allerdings komplett zu wolle gemacht
davon brauchen wir auch noch ein
bisschen was denn minütigen schwarze
wolle und davon habe ich auch ein
bisschen zu wenig habe hier eine weiße
wolle schwarzen farbstoff habe ich auf
jeden fall genügend mit dabei allerdings
habe ich am schwarzer wollte wirklich
gar nichts ich hab nur graue wolle und
daher fahren wir jetzt erstmal ganz fix
rüber auf unsere trauer insel hier vorne
damit wir die schiffchen schwarz werben
können und uns eventuell die eine oder
andere rolle spielen können denn wir
benötigen insgesamt sechs stück für
diesen banner oder dieses banner das
heißt ja dass warner sogar die frage ist
jetzt nur wo sich die stäbchen befinden
perfekt der bürgermeister werde dann
ganz kurz hier schwarz gefärbt und du
hier vorne auf wir benötigen sechs stück
insgesamt wir haben vier das heißt ein
schaffen müsste ich noch irgendwo finden
ich weiß nicht ob hier noch welche sinn
da ist niemand mehr ich glaube ich habe
gerade eine spinne gehört das wird
natürlich perfekt wenn irgendwo noch
eine spinne am start wäre könnt ihr die
töten hätten direkt die seite für den
webstuhl allerdings sehe ich hier gerade
auch keinen fall müssen wir ganz kurz
abwarten bis die schäfchen wieder wolle
haben
sogar direkt perfekt wir haben acht
wollen können damit unseren banner schon
mal machen benötigen ja allerdings
leider immer noch dazu den webstuhl und
deswegen müsse sind wir auf jeden fall
heute auch noch in eine höhle geben denn
ich weiß nicht wo ich sonst spinnen
treffen soll um die seite zu bekommen
deswegen euch mir ganz kurze time selbst
wie ich zu einer höhle fahre wo wir
schon länger nicht mehr waren
so freunde da sind wir jetzt auch schon
hier vorne in unserer bucht angekommen
der ein oder andere wird sich
wahrscheinlich noch hier daran erinnern
dass bei dieser krater der hier
irgendwie mal entstanden ist also unsere
insel befindet sich dort hinten am
horizont das brötchen dass ich jetzt
einfach mal stehen das benötigen wir
erstmal nicht jetzt muss ich mir erst
mal sicheren weg untersuchen die sache
war das da vorne nämlich seine höher
perfekt die sache war das hier vorne der
höhleneingang war
und hier haben wir noch nicht soviel
gemacht ich bin ja einfach nur
reingegangen und habe mal geguckt was
hier abgeht aber wir sind hier noch
nicht wirklich tiefer gegangen
vielleicht finden wir hier noch das ein
oder andere
wertvolle erz eventuell allerdings auch
ich höre schon die ersten monster ein
oder andere spinne
da oben haben wir auch schon die erste
ich brauch sei der deka
kann ich ja nicht das ist ja das problem
ich muss dich töten es tut mir immer so
unfassbar leid wenn ich tiere in
minecraft töten muss egal ob es ein
zombie ist oder
ist es nur bei tieren egal so spinnen
ist es ist doch so auf der grenze aber
so bei zombies oder oder skeletten oder
vor allem käfer damals keine abstriche
hier werden direkt getötet die sache ist
allerdings dass wir noch nicht die seide
haben
[Musik]
was sollen doch es geht los wenn ich
allerdings schon mal hier bin kann ich
natürlich auch ein paar ärzte mitnehmen
[Musik]
ich bin die ganze höhle gerade
durchgegangen der tablets hat nur die
kohle und das ganze eisen abgebaut ein
paar promis getötet habe ich habe keine
spiele mehr gefunden
[Musik]
aber es ist nacht
da haben wir schon den ersten kollegen
aha haben auch die erste seite wir
brauchen zwei stück nach vorne fahren
kann noch noch augen oder perfekt da ist
direkt die nächste spinne wenn die auch
noch seite drop dann haben wir es
eigentlich schon so sack und pack die
hat keiner seite gedroppt ich sehe
allerdings am horizont schon wieder eine
spinne oh mein gott die sind ja total
okay da war auf jeden fall der faden wir
benötigen jetzt auch noch eine spinne
die wir mal einen mehr haben ich dass du
nachher doch drei brauchen super wir
haben insgesamt vier stück das sollte
auf jeden fall ausreichend für den
webstuhl von daher müssen wir zurück
nach hause fahren allerdings
damit
kombinieren und nacht in minecraft ist
aber auch egal freunde hier vorne auf
jeden fall unseren leuchtturm her
gefahren und jetzt dann auch hier vorne
anlegen ich halte jetzt einfach mal hier
in unserer kleinen zauberinsel dass ich
da vorne direkt ich sie schon skelett
ich zeige euch jetzt wieder die
minecraft ml dies gilt
nein
ich habe das schon getötet
[Musik]
ich habe einfach davon getötet
ich wollte auf das skelett schießen
[Musik]
weil ich zwei hühner ein paar aus dem
weg davon ich muss hier einmal das
skelett töten sorgt super also das huhn
lebt noch hier ist papa ich hab doch da
vorne auch ein huhn getötet oder nicht
dass ich meinen sonst wird er nicht ohne
grund hier irgendwie eine feder liegen
die ich jetzt allerdings auch nicht ein
gewissen die feder
[Musik]
gefahren was sich getötet haben oder
aber ich habe auch keine feder gerade
und das home lebt auch noch
einmal sehe ich jetzt schon geister also
schreibt nicht gerne in die kommentare
was er jetzt gerade passiert ist ob ich
mich da gibt täuscht habe oder ob ich
das richtig gesehen
[Musik]
es sind monster in der nähe
wo sind denn die monster dicker
jetzt kein einziges monster
liebestod meine lieben freunde das heißt
jetzt müsste ich schlafen gehen können
perfekt wir haben alle sachen für die
netflix waren meine lieben freunde ich
habe noch nie etwas mit dem webstuhl
gemacht zu beginn muss nicht
zu beginn wusste ich nicht mal dass so
was minecraft gibt allerdings erwartet
uns hier ein wunderschöner morgen auf
los lukas unterliegen freunde also
erstmal checken ob ihr noch irgendwo
ungebetene gäste sind die greift mich
nicht an die mag mich weiter als ich
wieder fall haben wir das glück perfekt
sagt einmal schlagen zweimal starken tod
haben wir immer noch creeper zombies
irgendwelche gäste die uns unangenehm
werden könnten grund ist niemand das ist
seegras hier vorne ist niemand mehr hier
vorne in unserem wasserfall ist niemand
und hier in der nähe von balu man sieht
halt trieb aber nie so gut weil ja immer
so ein hohes gras ist ich bin das
allerdings ganz schön wir vorne noch ein
skelett das nur mal eben schnell töten
so aber sonst haben wir glaube ich keine
ungebetenen gäste mehr von daher können
uns nur auf dem webstuhl konzentrieren
ich habe keine ahnung wie ich genau
damit umzugehen habe ich kann ganz gut
mal ein verrottetes fleisch dem 1 1 bei
den sehr gegeben und 1 alu und den rest
natürlich selbstverständlich hier in
unsere kisten reihen zusammen mit dem
spinnen auge hier oben rein hier vorne
kommen die steine natürlich rein aber
fast kein platz mehr ist ein club der
schmeiße ich einfach mal weg brauche ich
ja gar nicht ich muss hier unten auch
auf jeden fall auch noch mal irgendwas
rein wollen wir da eine idee habt
schreibt gern und in die kommentare oder
falls ihr generell ideen gehabt was sich
in den nächsten folgen noch machen soll
schreibt mir das gerne in die kommentare
also spam die kommentare zu wer wirklich
angewiesen auf euren support was wir
jetzt in den letzten folgen den letzten
zügen dieses projekt ist noch alles
machen sollen ich nehme jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz meine kohle hier raus und
werde die so ein bisschen kohle blöcken
machen so dass wir ein bisschen mehr
platz in unserer kiste um haben dass sie
noch mal eben aufteilen und dann können
wir das hier auch noch mal im fuß zu
machen und da sogar auch noch keinen
raus zog dann hier die kohleblöcke rein
und hier die kohle reihen der rap song
komm mit mir hier unten mit reinpacken
mit dem eisen zusammen und das holz hier
rein das andere eisen was ich habe wenn
ich auch noch mal eben ganz kurz in den
ofen hinten packen so dass wir das
beraten und dann kümmern wir uns auch
schon direkt in den banner ich hab mir
halt gedacht dass es vielleicht ganz
geil aussehen wird wird im moment sagt
mir gedacht das vielleicht ganz geil
aussehen wird dass es dann nicht nur so
eine probe schwarze trocken wand ist er
trocken betonwand ist sondern auch ein
bisschen tiefer hat durch den banner wir
benötigen nämlich erstmal den webstuhl
den setzt sich jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne kurz provisorisch hin und das
banner haben wir ja hier vorne schon am
start und dazu benötigen wir noch zwei
schwarze farbstoff und zwei roten
farbstoff ich weiß nicht ob ich noch
roten farbstoffe habe ich habe auf jeden
fall noch roten beton und hier den roten
farbstoff also 23 roter farbstoff
brauche ich sogar allerdings habe ich
hier vorn auch schon einmal gesehen den
kann man ganz einfach zu dem roten
farbstoff verwandeln also das gas das
brauchen wir und noch einen stock danach
sind wir durch die sache ist was man
pepper hier
ja das sehe ich ich glaube wir müssen
anfangen mit dem roten farbstoff und
dann erst mal das hier machen haben
nämlich recht schon mal die rechte seite
von n und dann nochmal farbstoff rein
und da haben wir schon mal die linke
seite vom n dann muss der schwarze
farbstoffe und wir streuen nach unten
bis wir das hier sehen und haben nämlich
einen leichten verlauf bei dem netflix
logo kann noch mal den roten farbstoffe
rhein wieder nach oben gehen und hier
den zwischensprint dann könnte man zwar
schon zufrieden sein allerdings machen
wir da drum natürlich auch noch einen
rahmen so dass das ganze so aussieht die
frage ist jetzt wofür ich erstmal den
stock braucht ich glaube ich könnte dir
es hat irgendwie immer krieg
ich weiß auch nicht ob ich ja
mittlerweile ein bisschen paranoid
geworden bin aber er ist jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz was und werden uns
[Musik]
80 folgen alter egal ob ich jetzt am
anfang vielleicht werden oder nicht da
soll ich mir auch gedacht für die zweite
staffel minecraft mit luca 100 folgen
sondern stattdessen ein bisschen zu lang
doch die zweite staffel werde ich noch
50 folgen machen weil wir haben auch in
dieser welt schon so viel gebaut und
irgendwie komme ich ja mittlerweile
meine grenzen klar die projekte die ich
bauen wollte haben wir gemacht
allerdings das einzige was ich noch habe
er dies mit der spiegelung sieht auch
alles sieht man gar nicht so genau aber
hier mit der laterne sieht auch klaus
die einzigen ziele die ich noch habe ich
eigentlich ein freund fürs schwein noch
zu holen vom festland und den drachen zu
besiegen allerdings hat hier erstmal das
ding und wir haben
es sieht cool aus
aber ihr könnt das rot ein bisschen
knalliger seien allerdings bin ich
wirklich so zufrieden mit dieser
strandhaus villa freunde generell hier
mit dem ausblick einfach mit diesem
großen fenster was ich nach oben um sich
hier mit den bildern und vor allem dann
hier mit unserem teppich der durch diese
korallen fächer die abgestorbenen
angedeutet ist mit den kissen dann liegt
man hier kein bisschen netter explodiert
sky wurden dauer wir können hier links
unsere ganze welt sehen und wir haben
rechtzeitig eine toilette mit der
glasschiebetür unserer badewanne wohl
auch erst schnee geschmolzen ist und
unserer perfekten toilette
die mich wirklich am stolzesten
naja an der stelle wird hier heute wieso
dem eintreffen jugend allerdings auch
beendet meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat das kann einen daumen
hoch und ein video abonniert main kanal
und sich doch die blogger wenn die neue
videos nicht verpassen wollt übermorgen
die zweite mit minecraft mit luca und
was ich da machen sollte könnt ihr mir
jetzt bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte
bitte gern und in die kommentare
schreiben also schießt bloß scheiß bloß
ich muss ja ziemlich scheiße
[Musik]